you said you don't release shows very
often
and uh the question is or the requests
and the questions is what can you
tell dan to do one on the civil war can
you tell dan to do one on the napoleon
bonaparte
he tell him to do one you know ever
every topic and you've spoken to this
actually your answer about the civil war
is quite interesting
i didn't know you knew what my answer
but the civil war was that that you
don't you as a military historian you
enjoy in particular
when there is differences in the armies
as opposed to contrast
contrasts as with the civil war which
like blew my mind when
i heard you say is you know it's there's
not an interesting
a deep intricate contrast between the
two opposings like the roman civil wars
which legionary against legionary yeah
is and you've also said that you kind of
the shows you work on
are ones where you have some roots of
fundamental understanding about that
period and
and so like when you work on a show it's
basically
like pulling at those strings further
and like refreshing your mind and
learning
definitely done the research wow these
are like words out of my mouth yeah
you're right
so but is there something like
like shower thoughts on reddit uh is
there
some ideas that are like lingering in
your head about
possible future episodes is there things
that
whether you uh not committing to
anything but
uh whether you're gonna do it or not is
there something that's like
makes you think hmm that would be
interesting to uh
to pull at that thread a little bit oh
yeah i i
we have things we keep in our back
pocket for later so
uh blueprint for armageddon the first
world war series we did that was in my
back pocket the whole time
and when the centennial of the war
happened it just seemed to be the likely
time to bring out what was
that was a hell of a series that's
probably one of my favorites my rear end
man i have to tell you psychologically
you mean
just you know when you get to these i
think i'm guessing here i think it's 26
hours
all pieces together think about and and
we don't do scripts it's improvised
yeah so think about what i had somebody
write on twitter
just yesterday saying um he said
something like i'm not seeing the
dedication here you're only getting 2.5
shows out of here and i wanted to say
man you have no idea what the only
people who
understand really are other history
podcasters
and even they don't generally do 26
hours you know that was a
two-year endeavor um as i said the first
show we ever did was like 15 minutes i
could crank out one of those a month
but when you're doing i mean the last
show we did on the fall of the roman
republic was five and a half hours
that's a book
right um and it was part six or
something so i mean you just do the math
um and it felt like you were excited to
interrupt and on world war one
it felt like you were emotionally pulled
in
to it like it felt taxing i was gonna
say if that's a good thing though
because that you know and i think we
said during the show
that was the feeling that the people at
the time have and i think
at one point we said if this is starting
to seem gruesomely
repetitive now you know how the people
at the time
felt so in other words that had any sort
of inadvertently because when you
improvise the show some of these things
are inadvertent
but it had inadvertently created the
right climate
for having a sense of empathy with the
storyline
and to me that those are the
serendipitous moments that make this art
and not
uh some sort of paint by the numbers
kind of endeavor you know and and that's
to me
that wouldn't have happened had we
scripted it out so it's mostly you just
bring the tools
of knowledge to the table and then in
large part improvise like the actual
wording
i always say we make it like they made
things like spinal tap and some of those
other things where
um the material so so i do have notes
about things like on page 427 of this
book you have this
so that i know aha i'm at the point
where i can drop that in
um and sometimes i'll write notes saying
here's where you left off yesterday so i
remember
um but in the improvisation you end up
throwing a lot out
and so um like like but it allows us to
go off on tangents like we'll try things
like i'll sit there and go
i wonder what this would sound like and
i'll spend two days
going down that road and then i'll
listen to him go hmm it doesn't work but
that's
you know like writers do this all the
time it's called killing your babies
right you got
can't you know get no but people go so
this guy goes i'm not seeing the
dedication he has no idea how many
things were thrown out
i did an hour and a half i had an hour
and a half into the current show
about two months ago and i listened to
it and i just went you know what it's
not right
boom out the window there goes six weeks
of work
yeah right but here's the problem you
trust you're sorry to interrupt do you
trust your judgment on that
no no uh but but here's here's the
here's the thing um our show is a little
different than other people's uh joe
rogan called it evergreen
content in other words uh my political
show is like a car you buy and the
minute you drive it off the lot
it loses half its value right because
it's not current anymore
these shows are just as good or just as
bad
five years from now as they are when we
do although the standards on the
internet change so when i listen to my
old shows i cringe sometimes because the
standards are so much higher now
but um when you're creating evergreen
content you have two audiences to worry
about
you have the audience that's waiting for
the next show and they've already heard
the other ones and they're impatient and
they're telling you on twitter where is
it
but you have show the show's also for
people five years from now who haven't
discovered it yet
and who don't care a wit for how long it
took because they're going to be able to
download the whole
and all they care about is quality and
so what i always tell new podcasters is
they always say i read all these things
it's very important you have a
release schedule well it's not more
important than putting out a good piece
of work
and the audience will forgive me
if it takes too long but it's really
good when you get it
they will not forgive me if i rush it to
get it out on time and it's a piece of
crap
so for us and this is why when you
brought up a spotify deal or anything
else
they can't interfere with this at all
because my my job here as far as i'm
concerned
is quality and everything else goes by
the wayside
because the only thing people care about
long term the only thing that gives you
longevity
is how good is it right how good is that
book if you read jrr tolkien's work
tomorrow you don't care how long it took
him to write it all he cares how good is
this today
and that's what we try to think too and
i feel like if it's good if it's really
good
everything else falls into place and
takes care of itself um
and although sometimes to push back
sorry to interrupt this
i've done it to you a thousand times so
you can get me back please sometimes the
deadline
you know some of the greatest like
movies and books
have been you think about like dusty yes
i forget which one knows from
underground or something he needed the
money so he had to write it real quick
sometimes the deadline creates
is powerful at taking a
creative mind of an artist and just like
slapping it around
to force some of the good stuff out now
the problem with history of course is
there's
there's different definitions of good um
that like
it's not just about what you talk about
which is the story telling the richness
of the storytelling
and i'm sure you're you know again not
to compliment you too much but you're
one of the great storytellers of our
time
that that i'm sure if you put in a jail
cell and force
a like somebody pointed a gun at you you
could tell one hell of a good story
but you still need the facts of history
uh
or not necessarily the facts but you
know like
making sure you painting the right full
picture
not perfectly right that's what i meant
about the audience doesn't understand
what a history podcast
you can't just riff and be wrong so so
let me let me both
both oppose what you just said and back
up what you just said excellent so i
have a book that i wrote right
and uh and in a book you have a hard
deadline right so harpercollins had a
hard deadline on that book
so when i released it i was mad because
i would have worked on it a lot longer
which is my style right
get it right but we had a chapter in
that book
entitled pandemic prologue question mark
and it was the book about the
the part about the black death and the
1918 flu and all that kind of stuff
and and i was just doing an interview
with a spanish journalist this morning
who said
did you ever think how lucky you got on
that on that you know
and first of all lucky on a pandemic it
strikes you
but had i had my druthers
i would have kept that book working in
my study
for months more and the pandemic would
have happened
yes and that epis that would have looked
like a chapter i wrote after the fact
i would have to rewrite the whole thing
it would have been so that argues for
for what you said at the same time i i
would have spent months more working on
it because to me it didn't look the way
i wanted it to look yet you know
can you drop a hint of the things you're
keeping on the shelves oh the alexander
the great podcast i've talked around
the ver i i talked to somebody the other
day he said do you know that the very
first word
in your very first podcast in the title
the very first thing that anybody ever
saw with hardcore history is that
is the word alexander and because the
show's entitled alexander versus hitler
i have talked around the career i've
done show after i talked about his
mother in one episode
i talked about the the the funeral games
after his death
i've talked around this i've
specifically left this giant
alexandrian-sized hole in the middle
because we're going to do that show one
day and i'm going to lovingly enjoy
talking about this crazily interesting
figure of alexander the great so that's
one of the ones that's on the back
pocket list
and what we try to do is is um
whenever this we're doing um second
world war in
asia and the pacific now i'm on part
five whenever the heck we finish this
the tendency is to then pick a very
different period because
we've had it and the audience has had it
um so it's time
so um i will eventually get to the
alexander saga
what about just one last kind of little
part of this
is uh what about the other half of that
first 10 minute
15 minute episode which is so you've
done
quite a bit about the world war you've
done quite a bit about germany
will you ever think about doing hitler
the man
it's funny because uh i talked earlier
about how i don't like to go back to the
old shows because our standards have
changed so much well a long time ago
one of my standards for not getting
five hour podcasts done or or not
getting too deeply into them
was to flit around the interesting
points we didn't realize we were going
to get an audience that wanted the
actual
history we thought we could just go with
assume the audience knew the details and
just talk about the weird stuff that
only makes up one part of the show now
so we did a show called nazi tidbits and
it was just
little things about you know it's
totally out of date now like you know
you can still buy them but they're out
of date
um where we dealt a little with it uh
you know it would be interesting but
i'll give you another example i mean
history is not
stagnant as you know and we had talked
about stalin earlier
and uh ghost of the offspring was done
years ago and people will write me from
russia now and say well your portrayal
of stalin is totally out of uh
out of uh uh it's it's outdated because
there's all this new stuff
from the former soviet union and you do
you turn around and you go okay
um they're right and so when you talk
about hitler
it's very interesting to think about how
i would do a hitler show today versus
how i did one
10 years ago and you would think well
what's new i mean it happened so long
but there's lots of new stuff and
there's lots of new scholarship and
and so um yeah i would think that would
be an interesting one to do someday
uh i i haven't thought about that that's
not in the back pocket
but uh but yeah that'd be interesting i
have a disproportionate amount of power
because i trapped you somehow in a room
and
and thereby during a pandemic so
like my hope will be stuck in your head
but after alexander the great which
would be an
amazing uh podcast i i hope you do cons
give a return to hitler the rise and
fall of the third reich which
to me uh i i i really contemporary book
basically
yeah yeah and i exactly it's by a person
who was there
shira yeah i i really
loved that study of the man of hitler
and i would love to hear your
study of certain aspects of it perhaps
even an episode that's like more focused
on a very particular period
i just feel like you can uh tell a story
that
it's funny hitler's one of the most
studied people and i still feel like the
sto
all the stories or most of the stories
haven't been told
oh and there's listen i've got three
books at home i'm on all the publishers
lists now and they just
young hitler there's this hitler there's
that i mean i've been reading these
books and i've read about hitler i read
the rise and fall of the third reich my
mother thought i needed to go to a
psychologist because
i read it when i was six and she said
there's something wrong with the boy
and but but um but she was right but she
was absolutely right
but uh but you would think that that
something like that
is pretty established fact and yet
there's new stuff coming out all the
time and needless to say
uh germany's been investigating this guy
forever and sometimes it takes years to
get the translations
i took five years of german in school i
can't read
any of it so um so i mean and and
he is when you talk about fascinating
figures he's so
the whole thing is so twistedly weird um
there was a
it came out a couple years ago somebody
found a tape of him
talking to uh gender i want to say it
was general um
uh the finnish general manheim right um
and and he's just in a very
normal conversation of the sort we're
having now and you know the hitler tapes
when you hear normally he's ranting and
raving
but this was a very sedate and i wish
i'd understood the german well enough to
really get a feel because i was reading
uh what germans said they said wow you
can really hear
the southern accent you know little
things that only a native speaker would
hear
and i remember thinking this is such a
different side of this twisted character
and you would think you would always
you would think that this was
information that was out in in in in the
rise and fall of the third reich's era
but it wasn't
and so this this this is uh goes along
with that stuff about new stuff coming
out all the time
alexander new stuff coming out all the
time really well at least
interpretations rather than factual data
and those color your
those give depth to your understanding
yes you and you want that because
the historiography people people love
that and that was a byproduct of my
lack of credentials where we thought
we're going to bring in
um the historians we call them audio
footnotes
right a way for me to say listen i'm not
a historian but i'll quote this guy who
is so you can trust him
but then we would quote other people who
had different views and people didn't
realize that that you know if they're
not history majors
that historians don't always agree on
this stuff and that they have
disagreements and they
loved that so so i i love the fact that
there's more stuff out there because it
allows us to then bring in
um other points of view and sort of
maybe three dimensionalize or flesh out
the story a little bit more
you